oh go on bread my name welcome back to
some cry of fear in the last episode
Charlie got a Balu and he killed our
girlfriend after police bill he's just a
player look at him like in a random in
the middle of dish whatever she got
killed because we got rejected which is
I guess sort of somehow Charlie did us a
favor
I mean we would have been friend-zoned
for years things that would have been
coming why did that [ __ ] go well it's
been police bill did you kill her
well it bad answer me why you never
asked Oh what the hell oh he did love
her I'm really confused right now
oh god damn he got friend-zoned pretty
bad I got it's bad for the banner all
right I'm so sorry Sophie police bill
you did a good job
I guess you wanted the brooch after all
I got a keypad Sophie Sophie Sophie
Sophie
all I wanted Sophie watch the motorboat
your titties but no you just had to go
and kill your shells stupid girls they
never lesson don't they do they whatever
we're gonna go back here and since we
picked up a keypad that says TL trading
on it we're gonna go there simple as
that
and then meanwhile we can practice our
emoji quickscoping skills I got some
pretty leet stuff going on I've been
practicing those 360s and stuff so I
think we can do some pretty sweet no
scopes
I'm sure at least allow are you punished
with this one it's like back up [ __ ]
look at this they're out for a walk
isn't that lovely
okay so another day in Stockholm isn't
it
just doing some MLG outdoor a
quickscoping alright I think the door is
in here we'll see yes to the early
trading suburb how you doing
okay let's say use and we unlock the
door okay what's going on in here
garbage bag I think you're just gonna
blend and in the background I think I
don't see you can we go in here elevator
is all the way stuck come on
oh I play a Glock magazine I don't even
have Adam over the gun holy [ __ ] I'm so
stupid
come on equipment there we go ooh two
magazines I like that let's use our cell
phone and when I want it didn't reload
they didn't [ __ ] it so annoying if you
don't do it yeah this real long it's
really buggy that thing alright let's go
in a say what happens in hey alright
nothing special going on here nothing
special
oh it's just garbage bags aren't you
[Music]
mother of [ __ ] double headed by
bastards Oh a little freaky freak er ah
no that's not good for my boss they are
now tinier than a bee [ __ ]
this better be ridable and never is Oh
shucks okay it's okay it's okay
and we can say that's just the most
important thing right who the [ __ ] you
know [ __ ] Carrie okay are you it looks
like it's from South Park or something
what the hell is wrong with his head all
right it is freakin Batangas time now
bridge all right in movies they cry out
for Sparta for my country for our flag
but this is for Lady gaga you [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh that was freakin effective I
didn't think it was that good all right
I'll take your magazine of Glock and
then I deduce the drugs to get some more
Lady Gaga effect up in this [ __ ]
all right
I don't know I need a lady Gaga songs
wait I do alright I am in [ __ ]
translator Gaghan mode right now hey
don't shoot me oh it's on now
can read my can't read my no you can't
read my poker face she's got me like
nobody back up [ __ ] your head scoops
like a frickin put his head what am i
doing about you seeing it can't read my
can't read my no he can't read my poorly
speed she's got me like nobody but Papa
police people is speed polish bit bit
bit bit polish bit bit be let's go to
the subway station you know let's go to
- we stage clicking the buttons they
need fuse to open the door all right
okay let's go up the stairs like a mouse
I am The Boss I was a boss once but then
I was like policeman okay sorry about
that another awesome add our second in
there I missed the container
all right sir Oh Kenny there it's just
it okay where do we go
I don't get this is this a note for me
ranking system I not son Laura hello
there
Trevor the Rock has multi-millions and
why is the fuse donde esta the fuses
please Ben no okay I made fun of you
somewhere lamp do you have a fuse no he
doesn't
what did we came from that right can we
go in here no well that's fantastic
isn't it man may know what what is that
a gun awesome
I need those hammers oh don't shoot me
boy I'll [ __ ] you up all right let's do
this lady gaga's can carry bar hey
Ricardo you can read my poker face
tonight god damn I love when they
explode whoa no no no no I [ __ ] hate
those bring it back slap my best shot
stop my matchup oh you want some ain't
no party like a pity party ain't no Karl
a computer pop out it ain't no party
like a Peter Pan body that's what you
get barrels
I bet you working with them everyone is
working against me here let's go in here
brush
like me a [ __ ] you wish
okay it's not white I'm sorry sorry
frame went out of frame Oh Hank recorder
can't read my cameraman what else song
did she make I don't listen to her [ __ ]
but I listen to her music but in
supplying natural music it I hate you
I hate the chainsaw guy I [ __ ] hate
him so much I'm gonna turn on the roll
him a little bit cuz he's this is
[ __ ] terrifying
okay alright it's running like about
garlic butter Oh [ __ ] funny 18 walks
through doors now okay Ron come on to my
lab a little bit alright run run run run
run run Holloway Holloway I'll wait
Holloway for Allah to be very fun
burning thumb pom-poms carpet children
hand my dad
my job
we're talking everywhere tongue police
bin I don't Kelly
[Music]
it is not a good situation I think I'm
gonna call my mom and alright mom okay I
bet someone's gotta call that number be
like hey beauty pageant mom it wasn't
even a valid number see okay round like
a ball front look about
don't know back can read my can't read
my no you can read a lot o come face
she's got me like nobody can't read my
Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] through give me that
[ __ ]
gave me that [ __ ] oh [ __ ] me so much
please did I make it
then imma [ __ ] make it I gotta call
my mom
and punch the air show your titties
ooh you like that oh oh oh I'm sorry
that was just disturbing me alright
hahaha that's what you get but um that's
pretty [ __ ] good I would have my
tongue in this [ __ ] ok see you later
ally [ __ ] Gator that's for Hayley Mac
be engaging all right
this does not look good either not sure
I hate when I look and I want to stop
because I'm [ __ ] shaking and stuff
then I only record it for 9 minutes
smack my bad SHOP NOW bad sir not bad at
all so alright save people like about
someone said I could write bind save you
know bind
let's do f7 save pew it doesn't work I
don't know okay
bah what are you doing here trying to
flame dust on the barrel I will find you
mr. Dawson I think I have my suspicions
on another youtuber named Dawson working
with the Baris knew it I [ __ ] hurt
Shane Dawson is the leader of the
barrels I will find him and I will
eliminate Shane Dawson I will find him
and he will be eliminated
you too mr. burr paper thing lovely it's
a beautiful night in Stockholm I got a
safe let's take a seat and reflect on
life now or not I don't know
so another day another red car that we
have to slap slap you - okay ah come on
creepy corridors
I hate creatives I despise creepy
corridors mind a habit I'd say it's okay
alright it's a normal day in a normal
alleyway I think I have to wait are we
back here we've been here before haven't
we
yeah we have I think at least alright I
need to prove Oh magazine succomb safety
village alarm
oh yeah morale Samba slow get Cambria or
as Yelp or as Yelp porous Yelp or a job
sorry I'm sorry I'm okay we need the
fuse we need a fuels and to continue
alright so I guess we go back up here I
don't know mo GML mayor said stuff go
now right he are we really supposed to
go in here again I doubt that but we can
try I suppose
Oh via Piketty what someone say
something oh what's that
do you think we can jump from a yes we
can
hey what it is fine Swedish it sounded
like it said family OB but anyway let's
continue this journey [ __ ] really
that's what you get for not being an MLG
quickscoper I suppose okay let's try
this again the denim oh no you play
Mirror's Edge I love the part where you
jump in that really tall building come
on and it's sort of like that come on
wiring you're not jumping it's because
you have a heavy gun on you let's pick
the best tongue I guess I can't jump
why can I jump why aren't you jumping
I'm getting sick of this [ __ ]
last time thank you bro thank you
perhaps I was right you in my bro lace
after huh all right where's the VIP BPM
70 I want that gun I want it bad I
wanted our it all I want it now
all right let's save pew here so in case
I fall down again we can just adjust
this situation I'm the penetration and
the jumpy nation publish nation
relations lotion jumpy boss
sorry some [ __ ] was that
come on don't side jumped you saw that
that was not to me
no as my sin you're okay are we supposed
to go there I don't really get it don't
really get her don't really get it jump
like about jumping like about JP JP JP
alright
beautiful it's really beautiful
I like calm I myself is a Gothenburg Ian
but we don't have its fancy stuff but we
have the heart of the penis if you like
that stuff I guess so
why are you like that my god are we
going back here like about shape you I'm
so probably when I do it every time whoa
hey who gave you a gun oh he's gonna get
the fury of damage equates coping oh
girl I don't know what I was but I
didn't it
jump all right should not I wasted to at
least a man but it's okay alright
it's Patong day hello much a plant how
you doing alright another mission
planting all right that was what I was
looking for okay ah-oh have to do some
more jumping anything oh we're going
here how does that sound
all right we are gonna end this episode
here brass like and favorite if you
enjoyed subscribe technical hammer Brody
and I see you next episode I'm tired
okay that call you instead of that just
I do a little dance for you
I do really good teams I do a little
dance you want to play some music browse
you want to play some music bout you
want to play the music bear
[Music]
ammonia's consistent Nagas I am a
flourless blueberry pie no more a smart
little girl in your heart I have found
me a wonderful guy I mean when it's
tremendous a waiter
I don't know man they can't fart in my
heart
[Music]
Michael when I speak of that wonderful
God I'm driving the Asian air pollution
a coming true
I'm American right after moon happy pad
I'm not bi down their journey is
consistent now I guess I answer flag on
the fourth of July
no B or excuse me an expression I use
I'm in love I'm in love I'm in love I'm
in love I'm in love with the one yeah
all right I'm sorry that was enough of
that I do apologize anyway see you next
episode that was not a voice crack by
the way I have a DVD there in the
background you sits there all night long
doesn't do [ __ ] then all of a sudden
when I do my exit ticket did it you're
dead it's done that I okay
God what the hell is this shot